those lucky enough to be invited to the
coronation service are going to take
their seats Stephen Fry as you can see
one of the very first to go into the
Abbey uh Danny Tani gray Thompson
forgive me is there she arrived shortly
afterwards Maggie Smith been known to
play a Royal or two
in her time she was also there along
with Dame Judy denchu's played the queen
previously on the Silver Screen Emma
Thompson there as well with her husband
you'll recognize him from taking part in
Strictly Come Dancing
and is it him we were looking for Lionel
Richie at a garden party earlier in the
week at performing tomorrow as is Katy
Perry she's been told that she can stay
at Windsor Castle tonight ahead of the
concert tomorrow which she'll be
headlining and then other members of the
government arriving as well as you can
see Anton deck there